GUEST SPEAKER 1:
OK, so we are going
to be going through the
role of all tutorial today.
This is one of the Unity
provided tutorials.
And it is extremely good.
Like, I was going to
try to create something.
And I did.
And it wasn't anywhere
near as clear.
So it is here on this web page,
which if you could write down
how, that would be great.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Yep.
Unity.com?
GUEST SPEAKER 1: Yep.
[INAUDIBLE]
Learn/tutorials/projects.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: /roll?
GUEST SPEAKER 1:
/rollaballtutorial or you can
just Google, roll a ball.
It will be the first result.
OK, so this is the
Unity game editor.
Don't really worry about what it
looks like-- sorry, like right
now.
It will introduce that to
you when you guys go off
and do small groups to
start going through it.
But here is the end goal.
This is what the camera
sees, by the way.
And so you can move your ball
around with the arrow keys
and collect a bunch
of pick up items.
I need to lower the--
[LAUGHTER]
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Whoa!
GUEST SPEAKER 1: I need to
lower the acceleration values
in that.
[LAUGHTER]
GUEST SPEAKER 1: I played
around with a bit and yeah.
One quick side note before
you start going through.
The Unity editor has a
bunch of different layouts.
So sometimes when you
see these tutorials,
it's going to be a
different looking editor.
Let's see this one.
I think.
Yeah.
So everybody has their own
layout of the Unity editor
that they like best.
The default one
is not like this.
And it's not like mine.
And how you can change that
is through window and layouts.
I'd suggest experimenting
with all of them,
find which one you like most.
They all offer the
same functionality.
The panels correspond
to each other.
So when you see the hierarchy
panel within the tutorial,
it's the same as this
panel, even though it's not
the same shape, you know.
Yeah.
Is there anything else
I should go through?
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Is the
tutorial a video or is this--
GUEST SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: The
rest inside Unity?
GUEST SPEAKER 1: Yeah, so
they have a bunch of videos.
And these videos have the
corresponding code down below,
if you need to examine
it more closely.
They used to have the
corresponding code
in Java and Python, also.
But now they don't.
Unity is largely c-sharp based.
But you don't need to know
c-sharp, really, going into it.
It's very simple.
They do a fairly good
job of explaining it.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Do you want
to mention the reference, even
if you don't [INAUDIBLE]
GUEST SPEAKER 1: Yeah, So they
do talk about the reference,
but--
GUEST SPEAKER 2: So you don't
have the program pretty much
anything in Unity, else you
want to do something custom,
and then you add
a little script.
And the script has
a bunch of functions
that are pre-built into Unity.
And there is a website that has
all of those functions on it,
and f you need to do
something, you go look here.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: And this is
kind of intimidating right now.
But everything is
gathered in classes.
And they'll explain
these to you.
And each component
you want to access
is going to be
within a subclass.
And so Unityengine.windows.
And then you can access
your windows functions.
It's like speech recognition
or for getting files, etc.
Or similar stuff.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: If
you see some crazy
function and you're like, what?
Then it's probably here.
And you can go
read about it here.
And--
GUEST SPEAKER 1: There is
a handy search bar up here.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: So when
you come across something,
you come up here, search
for it, and then you
can read it in a little more
detail about how it works
and what it does.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
And like, similarly if you see
a command like, rigid body, add
force, you can see, OK, well,
this is what it's expecting,
a vector and then a force mode.
And that's it.
And if you don't
have those arguments,
It's not going to be happy.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: Cool.